Peter you say you fix scripts that are
sick what are some common illnesses of
most scripts 90% of the time it's about
a hero who doesn't have a change or
compelling change the hardest job for a
script writer and actually for a
producer or a director anybody involved
in a story is to make a really cool
character that you might think is great
you might have a really cool setting wow
that's neat we're in the South Pacific
you've never seen that before and this
is a cool character but they don't know
how to change him how to take him from
one place to another so time and again
what I do is talk about that point out
this guy isn't changing or if he is
changing it's not believable and and so
when a bad movie is bad often it's
because this hero's change is not there
it's not real it's not compelling and
sometimes you'll have a wonderful
setting and you'll have a wonderful hero
but he just doesn't change correctly
there's a there's a script that I teach
called killing on carnival row by a
great writer named Travis Beacham
blacklist writer couple years ago this
script felled him got him a lot of jobs
now Travis Beacham is is a fabulous
writer but he's not perfect and what I
teach in my in my classes is this writer
got his notoriety by doing a couple of
things wonderfully well he gave us a
world in this movie that's fantastic
fantasy and in fantasy half the job is
creating a real world you've never seen
before an original world like Lord of
the Rings a front the game of Thrones
but the other half is to give us
compelling characters to change and we
have a great character in that script
but we he doesn't go through a change
that has the depth or believability that
really would make us want to watch him
all the way through now Travis Beacham
is a genius at what he does but most
writers have strong suits and and suits
that aren't as strong and character
change has to be at the heart of almost
every
move unless you're making a superhero
movie where the hero doesn't have a
change and other things have to happen
there but so it's a long-winded way of
telling you that to change your
character in a story is everything and
that's what I do if it's not there
let's talk about a character that does
not change within a story versus a
character that does change within a
story I'll take a hypothetical let's say
we have a female she's 30 years old she
lives at home with her parents she's a
bartender she makes great money and
meets many interesting people but her
character does not evolve or change in
any way well let's say that her change
needs to be let's make it a personal
story let's say that she doesn't have
love okay so she's wounded
most great Hollywood movies are about a
wounded hero given a chance to change
okay that's what they are so let's say
that the reason she's wounded is that
her wound and it's always about a wound
in a story that's any good we all have
wounds I call them core wounds our
parents usually gave them to us so let's
say that her wound is that she can't
connect to anybody okay she can't be
intimate with anybody she just doesn't
feel it so she's a bartender so really
she doesn't have to ever have intimate
relationships she just has lots of
relationships with the people at the bar
but they never go any further than that
okay if she has any intimacy at all well
she doesn't and she's not intimate with
her family either okay so what's going
to change or what's going to make her
change well you have people who are
going to tear her wound wider open let's
say that that's the owner of the bar who
doesn't want her to change at all loves
the way she is and and tells her now
though that hey we're changing our bar
our bar is going to become a coffee
house and it's coming really important
that you talk to the people who come in
that's going to be as a barista I want
you to really establish friendships and
it's all about that and by the way here
comes someone who's a consultant who's
going to help you change and be more
friendly and also more intimate with the
clients well she really will hate that
she'll hate that she'll want to quit but
she can't quit she makes so much money
doing this so then you're going to have
also a person on the other side you're
going to have a let's call her an impact
Garrett who's a relative who says to her
hey your sister's getting married and
I'm making this a personal story your
sister's getting married and your sister
wants you to come to the wedding and she
also wants you to help me make this card
up that that it's a whole family and
everybody's in it and our heroine
resists that too not I want to do that
at all I don't want to be involved in
the family I don't even know these
people so right there you have this
personal setup where you have a girl
with a core wound as I can't be intimate
and you have her put in a position where
she's going to be forced to have to be
intimate or she's gonna wind up in a
tragedy and then you give a villain into
the story and the villain is a guy who
is just as disconnected from people as
she is and he sells her you know what
let's just have sex nothing else knowing
a Missy at all and she says great that's
fantastic I finally found the person of
my dreams but as we get into the second
act she begins to fall in love with this
guy and she also begins to realize when
she's in that bar that she's beginning
to feel the lack of intimacy and and
it's hurting her that she can't connect
to people so she's learning from this
person who's there as a consultant how
to connect because she's bonding with
her at the same time she's falling in
love with this villain who is gonna now
tell her when she reaches out to him I
don't want to be with you in fact I've
got a family so goodbye
that's gonna push her to change to heal
to reach out to understand she needs
intimacy so in the third act the third
act will be all about her helping her
sister's wedding
reaching out when her sisters say goes
into crisis and says suddenly I have
cold feet I don't want to get married
now our heroines going to have to
minister to her and say wait a minute I
think you should because intimacy is
good I just learned it's good and I'm
going to tell you one of the times in
your life you've been happiest haven't
they been with other people so she's
actually learned through
pain and learn through the fact of being
rejected by someone just like her a
mirror that she does need intimacy that
she does need to reach out and be with
people now that's a very small story
very emotional intimate story in the end
she reaches out to her family but she
doesn't have to fall in love this is an
indie movie this is a cool kind of movie
all she has to have as a small change
toward understanding
I need enema see I mean and in fact
that's the story of up in the air that's
a very famous movie with George Clooney
it's all about and it's a character
study it's just about this guy who's
disconnected from people who by being
pushed by villains and also pushed by
helpers learns how to become connected
to people that's now if it was a
superhero story or if was a tragedy in
the end she wouldn't learn that she
wouldn't have a change she tried to
change but then because she fell in love
with someone who was a bad teacher she
would be so crushed that in the end she
retreats and decides she's not going to
love she's going to go back to the bar
and there's no movement at all that's a
tragedy in fact that's the story of the
wrestler that was a great movie a few
years ago Christ's change looks like
they're going to change but has a mentor
that's so bad that when the mentor
rejects them and moves away they simply
fall back into their old patterns and in
the wrestler he goes back to wrestling
and he dies so you can build the story
either way it's all about who's there on
the journey with them impacting them
that tells you and shows you and them
whether or not they're going to be able
to heal and change or if they're going
to fall back into a tragic end Peter
let's talk about the first step in
writing a screenplay
yeah the first step is what turns you on
that's always what it is you should
never write to the market the market
will always horrify you right now it's
selling our superhero stories to the
studios but if you don't like writing
superhero stories you shouldn't say oh
well I'm going to write one anyway
because you'll fail you have to write
from passion and my experience yes even
writers who are professional
you right from what you love and you
right from what embarrasses you and you
right from your core wounds we all have
things that we love to talk about and
those come from our core wounds and I
say every storyteller is wounded and
their time to tell a story to heal that
wound we all have a dozen core wounds
I'm ugly my mother didn't love me I'm
badly socialized no one understands me I
go to a party I can't talk to me but no
one will listen to me I'm lonely I'm
alone I can't reach out I'm married but
I'm I'm not happy because I really can't
be myself there's all these wounds we
all have and we carry them inside
ourselves that's really what we're
always writing about always and this is
true for unthe arabised writers who are
very successful even if they never
looked at a psychologist couch and they
laugh at this when I work with them
turns out what they're writing about
always is their core wound so ask
yourself as a storyteller I don't what
I'm interested in what are the movies I
love I guarantee you when you do that
you'll find out that is your place where
you need to start are you interested in
love no I'm interested in computers well
then you might want to write a sci-fi
movie because you're sort of mechana
sized and that's your that's your bliss
but I guarantee you that comes from a
core one too so you must start with what
excites you and then shaping it is just
a matter of after you've done a passion
graft what I call just a draft of
whatever you want your story to be about
it could be a paragraph could be a line
it could be 50 pages then it's time to
think about how do I want to shape this
because the shape is always going to be
the same if it's a movie or a television
show the shape will always be the same
and learning what that shape is is your
job as a screenwriter is your job as a
television writer but it must have come
from your passion I always ask my class
stand up right now and tell me the most
embarrassing thing about yourself you
could ever tell anyone the thing that
would make you cringe horribly if
anybody knew it can you stand up and do
that of course no one will so I do I
stand up and I say look at my face and
when you look at now I want you to shout
this up but when you look in my face
tell pick out the worst feature in my
face and the best feature don't tell me
because I did a Korean television
interview or a while ago on the goggles
you have a giant mole on your cheek and
I'm like whoa gee I didn't really want
to know that but just tell me but just
have it in your head what's my best
feature and my worst feature okay now
most people pick one thing out and then
the other then they start doing you know
I don't want to tell them I know what it
is now I say okay now I'm going to tell
you a secret about myself something
really embarrassing
when I was a teenager I had this problem
and it was a very embarrassing problem I
had something called body dysmorphia and
it I don't know if you know what that is
but it makes you feel like you either
have something too big or too small
about your parents I thought that my
lips were the size of Mick Jagger so
that when I would go into a room I
thought everyone was staring at my lips
they were huge
I'd knock people over with my I wouldn't
kiss a girl in high school because I was
afraid my lips would get wet and then
they would look even bigger so here's
what I did about that all these things
came out of that wound in high school
for me one I wore white chapstick okay
which made me appear I was wearing
lipstick now I had long hair and I was
in a band so every time someone will
look at me I'd be thinking they're
looking at my lips are huge no they were
looking the fact dudes as long hair he's
wearing lipstick he must be gay that's
not what I thought I would also eat my
lunch in the bathroom because I didn't
want people to see my wet lips so you
see that this one wound or by the way I
got therapy I'm over it now but this one
wound was motivating all these things
they did I wouldn't have a girlfriend
actually I was a pretty good-looking guy
in high school but I couldn't do it
because I actually did have some but it
was a horrible experience because every
time I kiss them I'd have to use the
white chapstick so you see where I'm
going when I
tell people this story they're like
first of all they're sort of
uncomfortable and then they kind of want
to laugh and then they're just
interested because it's true
anything you tell about yourself that's
true that's embarrassing is fascinating
to an audience
all great story comes from these kinds
of confessions I call them this is a
device you use to make your hero
compelling it's a confession of some
embarrassment that you had in your life
we love to see that because we're all
embarrassed we all feel these wounds we
all have them and we see them in a story
we recognize them as real and we love
that person and we want that person
we're rooting for that person every
great story starts with a character
wounded like this unless it's a super
hero that's what that's a separate genre
that has their own rules but most of the
movies you love have a hero who's
wounded and it comes from the writer
himself and the wounds that he has and
how he tries to compensate for those
that's the physical manifestations in
the story of his behavior me hiding in
the bathroom me wearing white chapstick
I played football but I wore white
chapstick contradictions why I was a big
guy but long hair lipstick and I didn't
know it I thought people were staring
because of my lips no they weren't so
all these things you don't know about
yourself learning them is a story that's
what makes great story
so for fascinated by someone who's
telling us something that embarrasses
them yeah that's what we true though
that's true the person who pretends to
be too perfect mmm who'da flex it and
says oh there's nothing I'm not ashamed
of anything
do we then naturally not like that
person uh we will love them if we see
why they say that instantly okay for
instance there's a movie do you know
Jerry Maguire do you know the movie
house okay so when we start out Jerry
Maguire we see Tom Cruise and he's
perfect he's in a suit he looks great
like Tom Cruise always says he's an
agent and the very beginning of the
movie he
just as Sexy's can be but he's at the
bedside of one of his agent players he's
an agent a sports agent and he's he's a
guy who can't connect with anybody so we
think well this guy's an a-hole right
we're not going to like him what happens
in the first two minutes of that movie
when we have somebody like that we want
to punch him hard and make him change
and what happens is within two minutes
in that movie the little kid that is the
the son of the boy of the man who's in
the bed knows that Jerry Maguire is a
jerk who doesn't really care about his
dad and he says my dad's gotta quit
playing football he's had concussions
are you going to help him quit
jerem crossing hey your dad nothing
could make him quit super troopers
nothing he answers his phone and the kid
says to him hey you know what eff you
and when he sees that it's like a slug
to the heart and the next thing we see
him do is I got home that night and I
realized my life is a sham all I'm doing
here is for nothing it's just for money
I've got a change and he writes this
thing called a mission statement and now
we're with him because this is a guy who
has been enabled but now he's seen it
he's confessed it to us on the screen
and he wants to change that's why we
follow him so you can take someone who's
a complete jerk and you can make us love
him if you show this often through
confessional what his problem is and
that he's trying to change that's how
you make an unsympathetic character
sympathetic so many writers get this
note back from the producer he was not
sympathetic that's how you make him
sympathetic you show us his wound
quickly another quick example if you
don't mind you know the movie super bad
okay Jonah Hill fat boy in it very
unsympathetic treats girls like meat
then he confesses to his friend in the
cafeteria that when he was a little kid
he drew pictures of penises and he was
horribly embarrassed when these pictures
came out and he also some confesses to
the girl that he's not good enough for
her so even though this guy's a jerk
we're with him through the movie because
he's exposed his core wound and we see
he's trying to change bad movies don't
do that
most movies are bad by the way 70 to 80%
of films that come out do not have this
compelling change it's my job as a story
doctor to try to put that into story
because that's what respond that's why
audiences respond that's how they
respond Peter advice to someone working
on their first script I would say that
you must be super passionate about your
story you must be totally in love with
your story like nobody you've ever been
in love with like no animal or pet
aren't human being or house or car or
anything you've ever been in love with
if you're not in love like that and
you'll know then drop it and do
something else either write another
story or don't write at all because in
my experience the thing that makes
people succeed in this business is
persistence and now it sounds like
something a coach would say in football
and it's a cliche guess what it's
totally true if you aren't in love with
a story you're going to be living with
that story for six months or a year or
two now there are some people in my
business who say write a script in eight
weeks write a script in ten minutes
that's very seductive and they sell a
lot of DVDs never works
now you can outline your story in five
minutes I can help you I can tell you
how look here you've got this this isn't
this there's your three acts but it's my
job to tell the truth about how story
works you're going to be working on this
story for weeks or months to get a draft
and then you're going to be told unless
you are William Shakespeare you're going
to be told that there's a lot of
problems and you're going to have to do
another draft this all along this
process writers fall out because they
think it's going to be a week or they
think it's I can do this in ten days I
got the story in me completely I'm just
going to write it down and I'm going to
sell it I'm going to live in Malibu in
my experience that literally never
happens but it's
good sales to say that but I'm here not
to give a sales pitch I'm here to tell
you the truth so if you're in love you
will stick things out right when we're
married sometimes there's places where
things aren't all that great but we love
the person we're passionate about the
person we're going to stick it out
that's just like writing you have to
know that this process is going to take
time if you aren't prepared for that
then you will drop out you will fail it
is a matter of having the passion and
the confidence because you're also going
to be told it's bad almost all the
writers I work with that are super
successful are people who can be told
they suck repeatedly and simply go
you're not right and I'm going to work
again great example I have a friend
who's extremely successful now on
television a few years ago she wrote a
her first movie script she was a
stand-up comic and this script got three
huge actresses all vying to play the
lead in fact they all three ended up
doing it they came to her house to live
with her to see how she lived the script
sold for an enormous amount of money she
was just on cloud nine movie was made
came out worst movie in history
critics eviscerated it what did she do
she played us the tapes of the critics
telling her telling rut staying with his
saying cruel things she laughed at them
she went back to her desk the next day
she started writing again it totally
offered brushed off her back and now
she's she works for one of the best most
respected television shows on cable
there are critical respect as well so it
is about because she's passionate about
story she's passionate about persistence
and that's what she does that's a secret
on the topic of confessionals about
embarrassing moments what's something
about screenwriting that you're almost
embarrassed to admit that took you so
long to figure out
me personally that I'm no good at it
the reason that I'm a teacher and a
consultant and a story doctor is that I
my big secret is I don't enjoy writing
screenplays I tried for a while to do it
but it's not my thing I if PO 'try paid
I'd be in the chips because I'm a poet
that's what I love to write and I also
like to write novels but years ago the
reason I became what I am is I failed to
complete a screenplay it got huge
interest and I realized at the end of it
says I don't like this form it's just
not for me I love analyzing it
I love understanding how it works I love
helping other people do it but I don't
enjoy sitting down every day and writing
in the screenplay form it's not my thing
I love to doctor and to help other
people do it that's just my thing we all
have our thing so that's my thing so
that's sort of my embarrassing secret is
this is a craft
I adore analyzing and teaching other
people about that I myself don't enjoy
doing that's kind of embarrassing for
somebody who works in this field but
it's the truth and it's sort of been the
the wound that pushed me into deeply
understanding it because I did so much
want to understand how it worked because
I thought that would be the way in for
me to really do it well but it turns out
it didn't give me great pleasure to
actually work in this form how long did
it take you to figure this out well I
started really story doctoring about 13
years ago and that's after this big
failure - I had I had a story idea that
got enormous interest and it was well
we're on our way this is this is what
this is the dream and then I couldn't
complete it and then I start and so I
had crashed and burned and then I then I
started thinking why couldn't I finish
it
what is how does story really work and
as I started looking at our story worked
I understood this is my passion I want
to sort of I want to understand it so I
can show other people how it works and
how to do it but
don't enjoy doing it and that was a big
that took like three or four years to
really just sort it for myself but all
the time I was starting to get great joy
from helping other people with their
scripts and then as I said I've read
over 7,000 scripts so I started I knew
what these patterns where I developed
this story this idea this analytical
tool called the BMOC that everyone
started to love and it's a way of
writing around a an insight about your
hero which is about the wound and as I
started doing this I got hired by more
and more people and I just began really
getting passionate about helping them
understand and bring to to their story
what I'd learned about great story all
great hit story and that became sort of
my passion I still write poetry when you
say you weren't interested in the form
was it also sitting at the computer
alone and being sort of your own
taskmaster no I'm good alone it was look
screenwriting is a little bit like doing
chemistry it's it's or math or haikus
let's call it because I'm a poet I don't
know if you know what a haiku is it's a
very particular form you have to have
certain number syllables in this line
certain in this lesson that's what
screenwriting is like so you've got to
learn this pattern it's very precise
it's not like writing a novel although I
teach that too and boy if you want to be
freeform and not worry so much write a
novel although you still need that
character change but a screenplay is
very particular and television which is
what I do more now than T the movies
because TV is where so much great
creative stuff is happening today is
even more regimented right even though
on cable it's getting you can tell a
story now in double hours one of my
clients got a note from a producer I've
never heard before which was can you
make the pilot longer but even so even
though television is revolutionary
revolutionising the way we tell stories
in the jacobian way getting longer and
longer like the russian novel the 19th
century and that's why you know it's
great there's still this ABCDEF plot
structure that's very specific that you
must do that even the hippest guys like
Vince Gilligan half
to use in Breaking Bad this plot
structure is rigorous so that I chafed
at that I didn't like I don't want it I
don't want to have to have a second act
where all this happens nope that's not
for me I just I'm stupid rebel at heart
so the forum was so precise that for me
I just I didn't enjoy fitting my vision
into it even though I knew how to do it
didn't enjoy it just not my thing but I
love helping other people do it and I
love studying how it works and how it
changes and it's changing all the time
my god in the last three years
movies have changed enormous ly you
can't talk about things like 30-60-90
anymore movies are shorter the studio's
have taken over with their superheroes
that's a whole different discipline I
haven't talked to you about but it's a
particular discipline and it's not it
doesn't give me pleasure to do that I
forgot the question but anyway do you
remember the day that you had did you
have like an aha moment and you know
scripts pages went flying and said this
is it
I knew when I had this big insight about
how all great movies are structured I
knew no one else had ever discovered
that that was my equal MC squared moment
because this this this insight I had
helped so many writers and it became
sort of a central thing I still talked
about today it's there's four points in
every movie story when a hero's asked to
change when a hero's core wound is is
put to the test and that pattern is
there virtually from everything from
Star Wars took to pulp fiction and when
I discovered that it was like wow this
is this is cool this this I can give to
riders this and it helps writers
enormous Lee this this rhythm this
pattern every great story has it and I
don't think anybody really discovered it
before so that moment was when I thought
you know if I can just get that and
that's kind of what I'm writing a book
right now about and that's helped a lot
of writers so that was the insight that
really made me realize this is for me
helping people understand
how to tell their story in this rhythm
and it works for television - can we
talk about what a writer goes through
comparing and contrasting how working on
a screenplay the first week varies from
working on it the last week it's much
more fun the first week it's sort of
like again falling in love I always use
that analogy my god you know it's
fantastic you know you can't get enough
of the person you know you can have sex
every day you you you you're always with
them you know everything you do with
them is fantastic just looking at them
and my god
uh and then as you continue to work on
it it's still extraordinarily
pleasurable but things start cropping up
right how do we live how do we what
practical considerations or maybe you
start to see some things about them that
you know mayor you've got to work with
you have to live with so that's really
like writing a script you have this huge
passion for it
but then as you begin to form it into
this commercial form right this is a
commercial art form and I I but that's
delightful let's take the if you have a
vanity license plate we have a lot in
California you got to fit your message
in this vanity license plate in seven
letters right every commercial but the
delight of it is that you have this
constraint of this seven letter form
it's witty to figure out that let's say
I saw a Corvette license plate the other
day vanity on the 405
big Corvette you know and and the vanity
license plates that three inches so I
thought that was very funny right funny
ha-ha why is it funny well if you'd had
80 letters to say it you know I have a
really tiny penis maybe that's a little
funny but it's not nearly as funny as
three inches right so it is the
constraints of the of the commercial art
form the delight we take in fitting our
story ideas into this constraint they
like the audience takes and seeing it in
that form so when we constrain though we
must discipline and we must shape and
that's where it gets died
see four riders their second act is a
completely different story from the
first and the third act how do we do
that well it's a completely different
story but it's related to Act one and
three most riders get in trouble in
their second act because they got a
great beginning of great ending but
there's a whole 60 minutes in the middle
they don't really know what's going on
so it must be related to the story but I
didn't in it but it's involved with a
different storyline so all these things
go into into movie scripts and that's
where you need you almost mean to
talents look I think screenwriting is as
hard as brain surgery in fact I think
it's a little harder and the myth is
that in Hollywood there it's full of
stupid people dumb people who've just
stumbled into their success they're
smoking a slip spliff by the pool in
Malibu oh that's a good script on let's
do that one and then here comes more
money in my experience the smartest
people I've ever met work in Hollywood
it's a myth that it's full of dumb angry
jerky people and it's a myth Hollywood
pedals because it's fun people want to
believe that entourage is based on that
other movies are based on that but it's
just not true
Hollywood's full of the smartest people
I've ever met and by the way a lot of
them are really highly moral - again
that's not what they peddle because that
doesn't sell tickets that people want to
believe Hollywood's evil and stupid
that's fine they can believe that but
it's not so when you're writing a story
you have to it's extremely difficult art
to talk to concur you've got to have at
least three gifts you have to have a
gift for telling a big story you have to
have a gift for telling a story inside a
scene that's a completely separate art
and then you have to have a gift for
putting the two together in a
constrained time those are three
separate gifts it takes a while to learn
them you must have talent too so none of
this is to discourage anybody from doing
this but I want you to understand that
this art is an art that isn't going to
do you all as just a big package that
you can just sit down and write it all
out in my experience most of the time
the writers I work with that are really
successful are lacking maybe one of
those three or they have maybe two and a
little bit of the third but they don't
have it all so they have a process that
they have to go through to learn that
last gift and it can take them six
months a year two years three years to
do that very rare that someone just sits
down and and their first script that
comes out is it commercially it does
happen there's a guy that I've worked
with did do that but he's an
extraordinary exception he's a guy that
has made to to to hit scripts one of
them in dispute with the director so I'm
not going to give you his name but you'd
know this movies if I told you but he's
the only guy I've ever met who just sat
down and produced this golden egg his
first bump out of the gate and
Shakespeare did it apparently they say
Shakespeare never blotted a line I think
Marlowe says that about Shakespeare he
never had to go back and do a rewrite
but 99% of the of the geniuses clunk
what I work with they they do do
rewrites they do a lot of rewrites Ron
bass will obsess on a script for months
before he lets it out of his sight and
that's that's the general rule so it's a
difficult craft that takes extraordinary
discipline to achieve usually and toward
the end is where most people call it
quits yeah you know when I work with
student and I love beginners I work with
beginners more than anybody else and
beginners are always saying to me when
can I sell this am I going to be able to
sell this next week and be able to sell
this the week after this when is this
done Peter that's what they want to know
what am i through and I say to them
you're the only one that can answer that
question because it's up to you how hard
you want to work how hard you want to
work how much time you want to put into
it to sell it and um this is a field
where the success rate is is is is is
low in the sense that I think last year
100 and
60 spec scripts sold in Hollywood there
probably 20,000 submitted so think about
that that's not to say you shouldn't do
it because if you have a dream and
passion you can get it done I've seen it
done I just had a student sell two
scripts to a major studio now he's very
talented
Vladimir is very talented but he's also
been working for at it for four years so
you so many people who market script
writing classes and this is just a
marketing thing and I totally get it
I'll probably do it too book coming out
which is hey you know come with me you
know five minutes to a fabulous story
right and that's true in the sense that
I sketched it out thank you Peter but
it's not gonna be a sold script for a
while generally it just takes a lot of
work so that those last few drat the
last few polishes of your first draft
you need help you need inspiration
that's where I come in with my spiritual
cocaine and I give you notes that can
help you sort of get reinvigorated about
this story why do you want to do it in
the first place
you got a it's a marathon it's not a
sprint so you need inspiration along the
way I like to give that too but yes it's
that's the truth of it that's how it
really works so again bringing back the
screenplay process to a relationship
just like someone who might have a fear
of commitment in a relationship many
people out there what about when things
get tough with that rewrite and they're
starting to see the cracks of this whole
dream kind of fall apart who are the
ones that actually stay in for the long
haul even though they might have that
tendency often it's narcissus oven it's
people with big egos I'm just telling
you the truth but I observe ya it's
people who really think they're
interesting you know a lot of people
fail at things because they they see too
clearly oh look here's the odds and you
know there's a great movie here it says
don't tell me the odds right so in
my experience and this is true of the
incredibly talented woman I told you
about earlier had that that movie that
that that's failed so spectacular but
she just bounced back from it they often
are people who are very confident about
who they are very confident that that
they've got a talent not almost
impervious to people going you suck
because everybody gets told you suck at
the beginning and most people hear it
and go you know what I guess I do and
they quit everybody gets told it though
even the ones that are really talented
get told it but the ones that don't hear
it or the ones that just go yeah I don't
I don't suck I'm good that arrogance
that confidence whatever you want to
call it it might be you know it might be
a neurosis maybe it's because they're
sick I don't know but that's in my
experience when I look at who succeeds
they've got this rhinoceros hide and
they persist they persist when most sane
people would say hey go back to Missouri
you know you've got credit card debt
you've been trying for boomp years right
you're never gonna make it right listen
to your cousin listen to your mother
listen to your accountant who's been
telling you for years what a stupid
thing it is you're doing go back home
you're done those people go back home
and guess what they're done but the
person who doesn't listen hey they might
end up under a bridge too because you do
need talent this is not a job for
someone who has no talent but most
people I think and I'm not sure about
anything alike but for my observation
most people fail because they don't
persist now here's but you have to
actually do the work I know several
people who have failed because they want
to be writers but they don't actually
write they think about writing every day
and they say they're writing a script
but they don't actually sit down and
write every day now those people they
can fail
because I'm really not trying they have
a dream but they're not trying going
back to your own experience where you
were slated to write this script what
were some of the excuses that you use or
some of the busy work that you took hold
up to keep you away from actually
finishing it well um that you see others
doing as an excuse because they're
scared or they don't really want to do
it whatever the reason I think I I
didn't really know that I wasn't
passionate about it not it's C III I had
the dream but I didn't know that the
day-to-day process would be so
unrewarding for me that was what I
really finally realized is you know I
don't really want to do this everyday it
doesn't feel good it doesn't feel right
it doesn't feel it doesn't give me any
pleasure it's not my passion so I had to
realize that I just had a writer tell me
that the other day a beginner who's been
got a lot of success he won a contest a
year or so ago and he has told me a
month ago sitting up here I just I don't
want to do this I really don't I thought
I did but I don't
so sometimes it's really not our dream
and we need to realize that but what I
often see people do is not actually
write this is the most common thing I
see they don't actually produce on the
page every day they say they do they go
to classes they'll go to seminars but
it's almost like porno for them they'd
rather watch it than do it if you don't
write every day if you don't sit down
for whatever you decide an hour two
hours three hours it's hard to write
creatively more than three hours by the
way but some people do it but if you
don't actually put words on the page
every day then you can't say I'm a
writer
you're never going to succeed that way
and that's what I see more than anything
else I'll get another book on how to do
it I'll go to another class on how to do
it but will I actually sit down and
write every day no I don't feel like it
today I just I'm not I'm not inspired
today the muse isn't hitting me that's
what I see over and over again that
people do
to fail that's a big one so this weekend
if you were going to arm a screenwriter
with just one weapon or tool what would
that be what would that one tool or
weapon be well at my school at how
movies work in Venice the one thing I
tell beginning writers is if you if you
want to succeed you've got to tell a
story that you personally love and that
matters to you personally and it has to
come out of some deep place in yourself
if you try to write commercially or try
to write to the market you're going to
fail I see it all the time all I got to
write a superhero story so I'm going to
write it this is true for guys by the
way who want to write action who say I
want to be the next Tarantino you know I
don't care about you know jakoli and
character that matter to me I'll have
lasers and guns and stuff it doesn't
matter I've got 18 year olds in my my
classes who can quote every line of Star
Wars which is a 45 year old movie and
it's not because of the laser fights or
even the wookie or whatever it's because
that the story of Luke was the story of
George Lucas and he passionately wanted
to tell the story of a kid from out in
the sticks with a great powerful force
inside him that he wasn't using it he
had to go somewhere and change himself
and use that gift the force that was why
that movie succeeded not because it was
a space opera passion about your story
the truth about yourself on the page is
the most important gift you have as a
writer people Satan that's not true
Peter I'm a bore there's nothing in me
that's interesting and what I say to
that is I bet there's something you did
in the last 24 hours that you would hate
any of us to see some terribly
embarrassing thing about yourself some
pain about yourself you need to write
about the pain and pleasure and the
beam's you have of your own life don't
say that's a cliche every great movie
ever made
comes from that passion comes from the
writers passion and love for that story
there's only seven stories in the world
they've all been told a thousand times
the only thing you've got is a writer is
your passion your love your experience
that's what makes you different than
anybody else and what makes your story
different from anybody else and people
can people I see hipsters who go now
that's not true I'm going to make them I
mean I make a cool story about violence
it's just about guns it's just about
knives it's about the cool stuff that
happens and I'm going to say you're
going to fail that's not going to
succeed
Tarantino doesn't make movies like that
he makes movies that speak to him from
his heart that are from his secret
desires our secret desires our secret
pleasures are secret pains that's what
motivates all great story always and it
always will that's all you've got as a
human being to distinguish yourself from
from anybody else so it has to come from
there and you can learn the form I can
teach you the format how movies work I
can show you the rhythms but if you
don't have them inside of yourself
you're going to get bored and you're
going to quit so let's say you have a
student come back to you and they say
this is it this is what's inside of me
and you say you know what I'm calling BS
on this like I do that all the time
how can you tell oh instantly look hello
kill me tell you some okay here here's
another secret about myself
I killed a monkey in high school with
the drill now that's not true and you
could tell it's not true you can tell
when somebody's telling you the truth
about themselves you always know you
knew that story about my lips was true I
when I read a script and someone tells
me about them being a CIA agent in
Pakistan and killing somebody I can tell
if they're actually just sitting on
their couch in Thousand Oaks and they've
never been to Pakistan and they know
going to they say I know instantly when
the page is lying how do you know that
because we all have this
built-in BS detector when people make
stuff up we know it when people tell us
the truth about their lives we know it
we can tell and we're interested that's
the key distinction I tell you if you're
going to write me a story about a guy in
Pakistan who's in the CIA and as a spy
you better have been in Pakistan as a
CIA spy or spent about ten years living
in the world of those who did it are you
going to tell me a story that's going to
bore the pants off of me it's not going
to feel real at all that's how you know
you always tell the truth in a fictional
story you just put it in a rhythm and
you expand on it and if you don't have
the gumption to confess the embarrassing
truths about yourself confess them about
somebody else that you know really
intimately because everyone's weird and
we all know weird things about other
people but they must come from the truth
or you will fail you're going to bore
your audience they're going to know it's
not true that scene I told you about in
Superbad where he confesses that when he
was 11 he drew penises in class and he
had a whole lunch box full of what he
called dick drawings that scene is funny
and hilarious and it's simple were
sympathetic to this guy because we know
the writer that actually happened to the
writer
it's excruciating to see it on the
screen but it's got the ring of truth
why because we're all weird we've done
so many weird things in our lives that
we've never wanted anybody to know I
have you have you have and that's what
we draw on that's what we want to know
about you that's why gossip is stuff we
really want to hear oh you're going to
tell me something that's gossip oh I
want to hear why because it's
embarrassing it's true and it's weird
that's every great story what can you
tell screenwriters about selling their
screenplay that it's hard that to do to
sell your screenplay today the the
easiest way to do it is to well there's
three ways one is to make a short from
your movie shorts are sort of
the most powerful calling card to get
financing to get seen and they're almost
free if you can make a short and I have
a how movies work I have a class on how
to make a short and there's a lot of
rhythms in a short movie that you don't
have anywhere else you got to be able to
make a short from your script from your
feature script to do it but if you can
if you can do a 10-minute short of your
script you can put it up on a website
like Thunder shorts there's there's
several of them and this is where sales
agents today go I was on a panel with
sales agents the other day all they do
now - they don't even go to film tell
sillim or they just go on to these
websites for shorts and they troll them
and they look for really great short
movies that often come from
feature-length scripts and that's how
they often buy a story so that's one
great way to sell your script make a
short from it if you can't make a short
story from it chances are your script
itself isn't going to be very good
that's one way the other way is just to
work this circuit which is to send this
to the agents to send this to and don't
worry anybody's going to steal your idea
that's a beginners worry as well
nobody's going to steal your idea
chances are very unlikely because ideas
are a dime a dozen it is your execution
of them that makes the story valuable
not the fact you've come up with this
amazing high concept it's generally
that's that's not the important part of
your story it's how the story plays out
is executed so you send them to you send
you send your scripts to agents you send
your scripts to produce you to send your
script to the studios you do it that way
getting an agent it's it's really
important look there were more features
made last year than ever there were six
hundred features made last year that's
more than there's ever been made more
than everyone released in Hollywood so
it's a myth that the feature world is
dying but it is increasingly difficult
to get a independent type movie like a
drama or a small movie
financed by the studios or even by the
independence they buy them at Sundance
or now they buy them from websites so
you have to work around the fact that
the traditional ways in which
independence were bought you know it
doesn't happen that much anymore
but you still need to send them out you
still need to email your script you need
still need to get it patented with the
Library of Congress or through the
writers guild and just send it out send
it the more you send it out the better
chances you are someone's going to see
it the last way to do it is to interest
a star especially if you're making a
smaller movie a movie is a lot of the
people that probably are coming to these
conferences want to make a personal
movie a cool movie that about real life
a drama stars get these made you know
III was involved in the development of a
book that was um was never going to make
a movie until Brad Pitt it was a very
unusual story and it wasn't even very
good but it had a great premise when
Brad Pitt got interested in it because
he was sent this story then for the next
three years he just saw it through
several directors a couple of produced
funds Scott Rudin took it and they made
a fantastic movie of it so getting a
star interested in your your quirky
story is a great way do you and how do
you do that you just send it to the to
the stars agent go to IMDB Pro you'll
see a general email for most of these
production companies it's a myth by the
way but Hollywood doesn't read stuff
that they get over the transom in Oz
like it's a myth because you know who
gets that script when at the company
this board in turn chained to their desk
for nine hours a day and wanting nothing
more than to get away from that desk by
finding the next cool project chances
are if you send that script and even if
they go what you never read them well we
just turn them right around it's our
it's litigation we can't read them I'm
telling you because I challenge and when
they do read those scripts so and what
do you have to lose by sending them into
those production companies nothing so
what they say they turn them around
a lot of times they read them anyway
that's that's just the truth
suppose you checked your inbox tomorrow
morning and you get this email dear
Peter I've been selling annuities for 20
years I'm totally bored I came to this
town to be a screenwriter I want to quit
my job tomorrow and I had this great
script idea happens all the time in fact
one of my interns right now is a
multi-millionaire he's from another
country he just came here three months
ago because he said what I want to do
with the rest of my life I got all the
money I want I want to learn how to tell
a Hollywood story happens all the time I
say welcome come on here's how it's done
here's the form I have people from big
law firms in New York all the time going
I'm sick of being a lawyer I want to
come out there and and and how do I do
it because everybody who has a passion
to tell a story can wind up here this is
what makes Hollywood what it is we're
losing physical production in this state
because the political structure is so
stupid but the intellectual brain trust
of story here in LA is amazing you come
out here still this is still the land of
opportunities if you want to tell story
look we make almost 80 percent of every
dollar that is sold in entertainment in
the world today why why does Hollywood
make 80 cents of every dollar soul of
filmed entertainment in the world today
why I'll tell you why because we tell
the story of a wounded hero with a
chance to change they don't do it in
Europe in France you know you live you
die your life's over boom your bully
brings up daddy's auto BP in an alley we
are dead but in America we still believe
in this hero's journey this wounded hero
who can redeem himself by going
somewhere else and that's why we sell
all over the world that's why they don't
love us they don't love America God
knows they don't they love our stories
and that's because we understand this
myth that is every culture of the world
that guy standing out on his deck when
he's 60 and going I gotta get out
here I got a go somewhere and be
something different that's what we
celebrate that's why we're still
powerful that's why our stories sell so
come here come to LA this is the place
to be I mean it's it's cool why not I
came here that's what I did it's still
that opportunity for people and if
they're not a millionaire have a good
savings most of my other interns aren't
millionaire it's it up there are people
work in other jobs and and they just
want to learn stories so yeah I mean you
don't have to come here physically but
you do have to learn what Hollywood does
however that isn't luckily you can just
watch a lot of movies and you can just
see how it's done
watch the people you love watch the
movie over I'm no smarter than you about
movies all I did is get obsessed I'll
watch a movie 40 times and at the end of
that 40 times I guarantee if you do that
you're going to be a genius you're going
to say look what he does here Luca is
here you know that how movies work one
of the things I do is I have movie
nights where I just say hey you'll love
pulp fiction all come it would come on
in will view the movie together I
stopped it whenever I want I say look
what he does here look how he does it
look how he puts ticking clocks in every
scene look how we got the hero's journey
look how Jules is the Hugh he's an Old
Testament hero look the bullets missed
him it's a miracle and everybody learns
by the end of the movie how Tarantino
did it that's how Tarantino learned he
was a kid sitting at home watching
movies obsessively this is how you learn
you're not a genius you just are
obsessed